Hash
in
the Lord. Oh,
a shadow one.
All
[Silence]
I Oh,
I don't
Allah
Oh,
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Muslim.
forch.
[Silence]
for
now.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us of
the age-old argument
that is presented that is offered
by the disbelievers and those who speak
with their tongue.
It can really be broken down to very
simple terms.
Using Allah's actions
as an excuse to disobey his commands.
Very simple argument. Its premise is
very simple. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions as such
in
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala that which
translates to
and those who worship other than Allah
they say they claim
that if it was the will of Allah that we
not worship anyone one else then Allah
would will that we not worship anyone
else nor our forefathers
nor would we make prohibited
anything that wasn't his will.
So we have the argument being presented
here as
arguing against the commands of Allah.
Allah says
very clearly in no uncertain terms, it
is the first point that every prophet
and messenger presents to his people
and that is worship Allah alone without
any partners. And their response,
if Allah wanted us to not worship these
other idols and these other gods and
these other people and so forth and the
angels and the jin and the the moon and
the stars and the sun, people have
worshiped all kinds of things and
messengers were sent to correct this.
And the argument is if Allah truly
wanted us to only worship him
then he would have willed for us to only
worship him.
So they are responding to Allah's
command
his prohibition.
We sent to every people a messenger
commanding them, teaching them,
instructing them in no uncertain terms.
Worship Allah
and steer clear of anything that will
compromise that. Stay away from the
worship of anyone and anything aside
from Allah.
Very clear. This is what the prophets
and messengers were sent with. This is
the meaning of
[Silence]
and so our prophet sallall.aii Wasam
says,
"The greatest thing that I or any
prophet before me have ever said
isahill."
And so this is the command of Allah.
The response from the people who argue
whom a shan argues upon their tongue
is
if it were truly the will of Allah that
we not worship anyone else he would have
made it to where we cannot worship
anyone else responding
to the command of Allah
and citing the actions of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
But here is the thing this argument is
archaic as old asl himself.
This is their response as shan argues
this upon their tongue
and
causes them to be confused and confuse
others
because they are looking to what Allah
does
and ignoring what Allah says.
However, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does
not report to anyone.
He does not owe anyone anything or any
explanation.
Allah tells us he is not asked about
what he does. He does not have to answer
for what he does. Yet they all must
answer
for what they do.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does as he
wills.
He does as he chooses
and we must submit to what he says to
the commands of Allah.
This here is a dichotomy that has been
missed by
a huge majority of humanity.
The distinction
between Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
existential will
and
his legislative will.
He subhanahu wa ta'ala may will things
to be for a greater purpose,
but he only wills in his legislation, in
his books, in his revelations.
He only wills that which is good, that
which is pure. Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And nothing captures
this will of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
This existential will
[Silence]
subal
Subhan Allah.
[Silence]
for
this distinction is not captured in any
story better than it is captured in the
story of Mam
and
this story is recounted to us in
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
strongly encouraged
that we ponder and contemplate this
story at least once a week.
At least once a week we contemplate this
story. The story of Musam
and the story of Alisam
both prophets of Allah
both messengers of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala but they were both given very
different instructions.
Misam
represents in this story the legislative
will of Allah the will of revelation
and alis
represents in this story the existential
will of Allah
what Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala wills to
exist even if in itself it is not
necessarily goodl
the most evil of evil. Yet Allah
continues to will that he exists. Why is
it because he LOVES EL? NO, OF course
not.
But the human being has to have an enemy
in order to bring out the best in him.
And this enemy is represented
and emblematic inl
and his those who follow him.
He wills for them to exist
existentially.
But legislatively, no. Allah only wills
that which is good. The difference
between the two wills
is the difference between the human
being's will of aspirin and food.
We
don't love aspirin because it tastes
great.
No one ever took aspirin and said, "Wow,
this is really tasty."
We don't produce it and mass because of
its taste. We don't it in itself,
but we produce it and we will for it to
exist
because of the effects that can only be
had by way of this of this medicine
contrary to things that we love in
themselves. We love them for themselves.
A lot of times when we discuss such
things, people sometimes think, "Oh,
this is too advanced. This is too much."
Absolutely bare minimum knowledge that
every Muslim must have about his
creator.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE PILLARS of Eman
when our prophet sallall.aii Wasam was
asked
about El when Jirel came to him in the
form of a man with very black hair and
very white clothing.
He was not recognized by anyone but he
was clearly not a traveler. He came into
the masid and he sat very close to the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam and
he faced him and he learned from him and
asked him a series of questions.
He said
ISLAM
TELL ME WHAT IS ISLAM?
And the messenger of Allah sallall.aii
wasallam responded
that Islam
is the testimony that none is rightfully
worshiped but Allah and that Muhammad is
the messenger of Allah. that you
establish prayer, that you give zakah,
that you fast the month of Ramadan, and
that you make your pilgrimage to the
ancient house of Allah if you have the
ability to do so. He then asked him,
tell me, what is belief?
And he says,
for
[Silence]
he said
true faith the bare minimum what is it
based on
that you believe in Allah
in his angels, in his books, in his
messengers and prophets in the day of
judgment. And then he repeated the word
belief and that you believe in the
decree and destiny of Allah, the good of
it and the bad of it.
What is belief and destiny?
this distinction between Allah's actions
and Allah's will. The scholars have told
us from the time of the companions
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has a
legislative will and he has an
existential will and those two things do
not conflict.
Allah subhanahuaala
[Silence]
And so Allah wills that something be
because of the results, the effects that
it has. And then he wills that something
be because it is good in itself.
And those are the wills of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Making this
distinction is critical in order that
our belief in Allah and his decree
be complete.
And what better story than the story of
Misam?
He represents the legislative will of
Allah. what Allah commands in his books,
in his revelations,
what he commands us to do and not do.
And al embodies and represents the
existential will of Allah. Things that
Allah may not love for themselves,
destruction,
destructive things, things that bring
about pain, things that bring about
suffering.
But for the greater good
in Bkari Abdullahb
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam's
cousin
and the most knowledgeable companion of
the book of Allah
abdah Abbas narrates the story of Mus
he says that the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam said that Misam
was once with his people ban
and they asked HIM A QUESTION. THE
QUESTION in itself was an unnecessary
question.
It's a question that reflects the
mindset
of Benny is at the time that Allah
dispraised that they asked questions
that they had no business asking and
they left off other things that they
were desperate to know.
And so if Mus Alam
would tell them a story, they would ask
about
things that are peripheral at best with
that story. Missing the point, he
commanded them to slaughter a cow. Well,
how old was the cow and what color is
the cow and what does the cow do for
a living, etc.
questions that completely miss the
point.
But this is how they were and we are to
learn from their mistakes. And so they
asked Musam,
"Who is the most knowledgeable person on
all of the earth?" Musam responded with
that which he knew at the time. He said,
"Me."
And he should have responded as the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam teaches us.
Allah knows best.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent to
him that he is to travel to meet someone
that has more knowledge than misam.
This is incredible. Musam
speaks directly to Allah.
He is.
He speaks directly with Allah. Direct
dialogue with Allah.
And so he set out with his servant Yosha
Albon who would later be appointed a
prophet after Mus Alisam
to go meet who we would later find out
is Alab.
And when he met him, Alab proceeded to
do things that contradict the
commandments of Allah in the Tawra.
But al was a messenger in his own right
and he was not bound by
Musam was sent to Ben and Alad is not
from Beni.
And so they rode in a ship. They arrived
at a sea at the sea. They wanted to ride
these poor merchants on this ship. They
took them on
without any pay. They said, "No, just
ride. Come on." It was a very good deed.
And as they're on this ship, a bird,
as the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said, a bird landed on the edge of the
ship. Imagine there we have Mam, we have
Al. They are out in the sea, the Red
Sea, and this bird lands on the edge of
a of the ship as they're both watching.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam says
the bird then pecked at the water and
took a sip of the water from the sea.
And
having seen this with MS turned to Mam
and said,
the two most knowledgeable men on earth.
We have one who speaks directly to
Allah, the greatest messenger of ben is
and we have
who is the most knowledgeable of the
existential will of Allah. He is given
he is privy to knowledge of things that
haven't occurred yet.
These two men al turns to him and he
says, "My knowledge and your knowledge
combined
with respect to the knowledge of Allah
is the sip that this bird just took
from the sea.
It's nothing.
[Silence]
He said knowledge is but a drop
and it was expanded by the ignorant
people.
People of ignorance who pursue that
which they HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE OF. They
made knowledge more than what it is.
And they took us into things and aspects
of the book of Allah that were very
similar to the aspects that were delved
into by the scholars of Benny is
and so Mus Alam watches that these very
good men they took us on their ship for
free. We didn't have to pay anything.
They were very nice to us. And how does
Alabar repay them? He starts ripping
planks out from the hole of the ship and
puts a hole in it.
No explanation,
no arguing, nothing. He just proceeds to
put a hole in their ship and then stand
back and watch the workers on this boat
converge on this hole on this hole and
start to frantically try not to sink and
drown.
Why would he possibly why would he do
this? It appears that he is repaying
good doers with bad. But Allah teaches
this is not how you thank people.
Inshallah
we will continue this story in our next
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Align your
shoulders and your feet with the
shoulders and feet of your two
neighbors. Please ensure that your
phones are silent.
Do not join a row until you are sure
that the row in front of you is
[Arabic recitation]
What was I doing?
for
[Silence]
al
me
Allahel.
Allah
belt.
[Arabic recitation]
announcements. First, alhamdulillah, the
summer camp has concluded today and we
are requesting the survey feedback to
improve the program for the future
inshallah. The survey program survey
feed the that survey form is available
through sister ona or any other
administrator that you know or the
teacher in the class. Please make sure
that you provide the feedback to us so
we could improve the program in the
future. Also want to thank Imam Sheh Ali
and everybody who worked with him to
make that program as good as enjoyable
as possible. Alhamdulillah.
We also have tonight after Mghreb that
youth program that's a weekly activity
that will be every Friday night
inshallah. The first one was last week.
Today is the second one. And please
bring your youth youngster with you to
join as from MAGB to Isha. And there
will be a hadith lecture after the first
after the you know the after mab
inshallah. So that is a very beneficial
please bring your youth and get
connected to the masjid inshallah. Also
one announcement that I to make
is my daughter-in-law's f the my
daughter in-law's uncle passed away in
Pakistan.
May Allah grant him mercy and enter him
in Jenna
and please donate generously on the way
out.
[Silence]
Good to see you.
So